- Hi, I'm Levar Burton.
This is my throne of books!
And, these are some of the most
beautiful quotes in Literature.
(classical music)
"At any rate, that is happiness,
"to be dissolved into something
complete and great."
"Isn't it pretty to think so?"
"He stepped down trying
not to look long at her,
"as if she were the sun, yet he saw her,
like the sun even without looking."
"Whatever our souls are made of,
"his and mine are the same."
"There is a sense in which
"we are all each other's consequences."
"Let the wild rumpus start!"
"You don't have to live forever.
"you just have to live."
"And the rest is rust and stardust."
"A dream, all a dream,
that ends in nothing
"and leaves the sleeper where he lay down
"but I wish you to know
that you inspired it."
"Journeys end, in lovers meeting."
"Everything was beautiful
and nothing hurt."
(classical music)